chers amis nous allons nous allons
commencer parce que nous avons une une
matinée rempli je pense que nos
personnes intéressées arrivons au fur et
à mesure comme d'habitude mais nous
allons respecter là alors on recommence
notre notre sigle de convention qui
s'était brutalement interrompu au moment
évidemment de ces sinistres avantage
attentats qui nous ont touchés
il ya maintenant quelques mois
et puis après la période de noël donc
nous reprenons ce site et nous allons
évidemment l'accélérer aujourd'hui nous
allons parler évidemment de ce sujet qui
est éminemment important important sur
le fond important aussi dans la
conjoncture qui est l'agriculture et qui
est la ruralité
nous travaillerons un petit peu dans
quelques semaines sur la fonction
publique et la réforme de l'état appuie
sur les thèmes économiques puis sur les
thèmes sociaux puis sur l'école il voir
un programme très dense des républicains
notre parti est en ordre de marche
il a reconstitué ses équipes sur le
terrain dans les départements cette
semaine ce samedi et ce dimanche les
militants ont voté et nous avons
maintenant l'intention de nous
concentrer sur le projet sur nos
propositions nous hélène nos analyses
aussi thème par thème avant de
globaliser tout cela dans un projet
d'ici l'été
alors l'agriculture et la ruralité ces
deux sujets a priori que pour qu'on peut
considérer comme distincts et pourtant
il ce recours la ruralité ne se résume
pas bien sûr à l'agriculture et les
problèmes de l'agriculture sont souvent
d'un tout autre ordre ou tout autre
ordre que les questions qui se posent à
la ruralité mais ces deux sujets sont
évidemment intimement liée intimement
liés par la géographie intimement liée
aussi parce que l'agriculture c'est la
première activité économique de la
ruralité
nous avons souhaité pouvoir lier les
deux et puis l'actualité est évidemment
tournés me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
vernon vers nos campagnes
l'agriculture c'est une crise sans fin
mais c'est une crise aujourd'hui qui
atteint des niveaux
rarement atteint la désespérance des
paysans est considérable et je pense
qu'elles que soient les filières ils ont
bien du mal à voir le bout du tunnel et
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
évidemment le désespoir rejoint la
colère la désespérance des éleveurs
comme on aurait pu le voir dès cet été
bien avant mais dès cet été encore plus
fort qui se poursuit et les autres
filières qui au fur et à mesure du temps
sombres dans dans la crise nous en face
de cela le gouvernement agit peu plus
nice fait autre chose
les agriculteurs l'ont souvent dénoncés
ils ont raison ils ont besoin d'un
ministre a plus que dans pleins son
besoin d'un ministre qui se battent à
bruxelles et qui se battent ici sur le
terrain et les actions proposées par le
gouvernement sont évidemment pas du tout
à la hauteur non pas des attentes
puisque c'est pas que des attentes mais
des réalités des agriculteurs
d'aujourd'hui il faut donc informés il
faut transformer il faut réformer
l'agriculture il faut se battre en
france il faut le battre en europe pour
que notre indique agriculture soit la
première d'europe et souhaite une
agriculture considéré comme une activité
économique à part entière
quant à la ruralité c'est un sentiment
d'abandon qui domine dans notre ruralité
un sentiment d'abandon économique un
sentiment d'abandon technique un
sentiment d'abandon culturel de mobilité
enfin il ya un bref le sentiment que il
ya une énorme inéquité territoriales ce
sentiment se transforme aujourd'hui en
ressentiment ressentiment contre les
politiques ressentiment contre une
société française qui abandonnerait la
ruralité au profit des devil et ce
sentiment se traduit évidemment aussi
dans les urnes on a pu le remarquer au
moment des élections régionales
la colère était partout dans nos
villages et dans nos dans nos dans nos
milieux ruraux quel que soit d'ailleurs
les départements qu'ils soient du nord
du sud qu'il soit peu éloigné grande
métropole à partir du moment où le mode
de vie est un mode de vie à dominante
rurale la colère s'est exprimée sans
sans frein au moment de ces élections
régionales tous ces sujets on va les
aborder
on va les aborder durant cette matinée
nous allons commencer par écouter et
entendre des témoignages sur cette crise
agricole et c'est isabelle le callennec
qui présidera cette séquence puis jean
pierre vigier animera une table ronde
très dense sur la vision d'avenir que
nous pouvons porter sur notre
agriculture est évidemment sur les
conditions qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
pour porter cette vision d'avenir
et puis angers ligue 2 là notre député
européen nous parlera évidemment de
l'europe et de l'agriculture en
présidant cette table ronde majeur pas
d'agriculture aujourd'hui sans une
politique européenne forte et puis on
passera vers 11 heures du matin avec
jean louis costes et pierre morel à
l'huissier a à ce travail sur la
ruralité à cette vision que nous avons
des territoires ruraux et aux
propositions que nous pourrons faire
pour essayer de faire en sorte que les
territoires ruraux ne se sent plus des
délaissés de la république et puis
nicolas sarkozy viendra bien sûr comme
d'habitude conclure cette matinée de
travail je cède immédiatement la parole
à isabelle le callennec